this industry I've learned that every
once in a great while you can get be
part of something special this is one of
those moments in the past two and a half
years we put some of es greatest talent
and most advanced technology together
with one of the most beloved sagas of
our time as we seek to create something
that millions of fans around the world
will love the passion creativity and
dedication come from our die studio in
Stockholm the technology is EA's own
frostbite game engine and the game is of
course Star Wars Battlefront
now frostbite powers many of the games
you've seen here today
looking ahead frostbite will be at the
core of even more EA games including
experiences for mobile devices and maybe
one day even VR right now the
sophistication of frostbite is bringing
a galaxy far far away to life like never
before in just a few moments you'll see
how tools like physically based
rendering new weathering systems and a
technique called photogrammetry are
being used to create an incredibly
detailed immersive and completely
authentic experience in star wars
battlefront we're still only beginning
to see what frostbite can truly achieve
but the results are completely stunning
so let us show you made by developers
that love Star Wars for fans the love
Star Wars let's step into the world of
Star Wars Battlefront
[Applause]
I'm Selena infertile debt and I have the
awesome job of leading a talented
passionate team at dice on Star Wars
Battlefront like many of you I can't
remember a time when Star Wars wasn't a
part of my life one of my earliest
memories is of seeing a touch on Mona's
being that I was terrified of not being
whose mask still has the ability to
strike fear in me is Darth Vader I
remember playing with the old action
figures or attaching a clothespin to a
magic marker to create a blaster pistol
so I could run around shooting lasers at
the matura stormtroopers today by far
the best place to truly lose yourself
and interact with Star Wars is video
games with Star Wars Battlefront
we will immerse players in an incredibly
authentic visually stunning universe and
we've gotten amazing access from our
partners at Lucasfilm they've opened up
their sacred words to us so that we can
recreate the props and locations from
the original trilogy
when you fly in an x-wing it's the real
x-wing we will give you the chance to
live out the Star Wars battle fantasies
you've always dreamed of and we can't
wait to see all of the new memories you
will create on your own we have a great
amount of depth a variety of multiplayer
modes that range from large-scale
battles between 40 players all the way
down to 8 player modes that deliver a
more intimate experience between sports
of rebel and imperial soldiers have you
ever wanted to fly an x-wing soaring
above the skies skimming the rims of
canyons on Tatooine
while you dogfight against a squad of
fire fighters or have you fantasized
about being one of the most iconic
heroes or villains in the Star Wars
universe wielding a lightsaber and using
the force being the boss of a
multiplayer maps and single-handedly
turning the tide of an epic Star Wars
battle and if you're not in the mood for
multiplayer we have Star Wars bathroom
admissions where you can jump in and
play against AI alone or with a friend
including split-screen power and
one-on-one pockets now it's been two
months since we revealed sparrows
backdrop and we've been amazed by the
response but if there's one thing that's
come through loud and clear is that you
want to see gameplay so that's what
we're going to do right now
[Applause]
what we're about to show you today is
Walker assault one of our largest loads
this mode was inspired by the Battle of
Hoth from the Empire Strikes Back as the
Empire you must escort 80 80 workers
towards the rebel base to destroy it and
as the rebels you must do everything you
can to stop them and while you will see
a lot of things that reminds you of that
iconic battle when you play the game
your way anything is possible this was
all captured on a Playstation 4 and you
will see the button from the message
point to both the Empire and the rebels
now let's play Star Wars
[Applause]
[Music]
Arielle
two little walk reach the base
gee I can't coming targeting our face
the rebels have activated the update on
that position
grevilles just lost their uplink
the Bombers can't help us unless we
protect you
well done
the rebels have activated the uplink
station we must shut it down
[Music]
incoming orbital strike
police coming
hang in there houses all the way
fifteen going in
this is route 12 accelerating to attack
speed
[Music]
exposed focus on firepower on it
Roma's are making it go in for the
takedown
almost there
Walker has been taken out yes
walk her down
[Music]
Oh 15
my wings are making that attack
we've gotta pull this last position roll
at the car
[Music]
the
core is exposed take it out
[Music]